[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hello
and welcome to
YouTube Developers Live.
We have an exciting show
for you today.
My name is Jarek Wilkiewicz,
I work for
YouTube Developer Relation.
And we have a special guest
today, Adrian Holovaty, about
joining us live from Chicago
using a Hangout.
How are you doing, Adrian?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Hey, good.
Nice to be here.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thank you very
much for joining today.
Is it snowy out in Chicago?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: No.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Spring
has started.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Not snowy.
It appears to be clear
outside today.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So I understand you've been
working on a new project for a
little while.
I know that you were one of the
main folks behind Django,
but this project is a
little different.
Is it true?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Yes, it is
a tool for musicians.
It has absolutely nothing to do
with what I did previously,
which was a local news site
called EveryBlock and it uses
Django but it's not a web
development tool, it's a tool
for musicians.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So how did
you come up with the idea?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Well, I spend
a lot of my free time trying
to basically reverse
engineer songs.
So I'll have something like a
jazz solo that I want to learn
and it's not available online
anywhere, or it's not in a
book that I can buy like sheet
music, so I'll just sit with
the recording and try to figure
out how to play it.
And that's a really
laborious process.
And it also is really
ineffective in terms of learning.
So I would learn a little
piece of music from some
recording and I would write it
down on a piece of paper so I
could preserve what I learned.
But then when I came back to
that piece of paper a couple
days later, I'd be like, I don't
even understand this.
And I would have to listen to
the original recording along
with looking at my notes to
actually understand it.
So I wanted to make something
that marries the recorded
music, the actual recording,
with the transcription of it,
which is the notes that
you're playing.
And that's what Soundslice
does.
It's a way of-- still working
on the pitch, clearly--
it's a way of--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: You're
doing fine.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: It's a way of
combining sheet music with an
actual recording, specifically
using YouTube videos, so we
can basically annotate any
YouTube video with musical
information.
You can say like from here to
here in the video he's playing
an A minor, from here
to here he's playing
this note, or whatever.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So is it fair
to say that you created
the product for yourself as the
main prototypical user or
what was the inspiration?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Definitely,
yeah.
It's definitely for myself
first and foremost.
The best products scratch
your own itch.
Yeah, it's for myself.
I've learned a ton of stuff.
I've played guitar around
Chicago and I'm always looking
new licks to use in my solos.
And I've learned probably more
than 100 licks and songs and
stuff from it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So why
don't we do this.
So I understand you are ready
to give us a little demo.
Are you?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And then after
that I would like to
test to see how well your
product has served you.
And if you wouldn't mind playing
something live for us,
we would really appreciate
it and I'm sure
so would the viewers.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Let's do it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
So let's see the demo first.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: OK, let me
pull this guy up here.
So let's see.
Can you see this?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes,
we can see it.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Awesome.
Well, this is an example of
a completed Soundslice
transcription.
So I have here a YouTube video
which is me playing "The Star
Spangled Banner." And then here
you have a timeline view
of the song.
So you can just scroll it.
You see the notes as they're
played in the song.
And I'll go ahead and play it
so you can see how it all
comes together.
[MUSIC - "THE STAR
SPANGLED BANNER"]
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: So I won't
play the whole thing.
That basically gives you
a little taste of it.
It's got a lot of UI
stuff that I won't
go into detail of.
You can zoom in and zoom out,
see the whole song.
Loop sections--
so if I want to just focus
on this beginning part.
[SINGS FIRST MEASURE]
I can just highlight that
part and play it.
[MUSIC - "THE STAR
SPANGLED BANNER"]
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: And
it will loop it.
Another thing that's really
useful for learning a song is
slowing it down to half speed
without changing the pitch, so
I can just click here.
And it's super slow.
[MUSIC - "THE STAR
SPANGLED BANNER"]
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Like the two
bedrock bits of music
transcription--
learning a song-- are looping
sections and slowing it down.
So those are the two things
I just showed.
And the site lets you search
for any YouTube video and
create these transcriptions
that are
perfectly synced with them.
And that's the quick tour.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: No,
this is great.
So a couple of questions.
So this transcription process
is manual, right?
This is something that you
rely on the user to do.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Yeah, it's
manual because I don't have
access to the MP3s of
the YouTube videos.
I'll be adding a different
version, sort of like a Pro
account, that lets you
upload an MP3.
And if I have access to the
MP3, then I can do an
automated first pass at the
transcription, I can add a
waveform display, which makes
it a lot easier to navigate,
and a bunch of other stuff.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
Yeah, correct.
We don't have that in
the API right now.
And then another question I had
is so is this is a single
user product?
Are they any collaboration
features?
Any sharing features?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY:
Good question.
So it's sort of half and
half at the moment.
See here we have tracks.
So there's the sections
of the song.
There's the chords and then
there's the actual notes.
Anyone can create a track or as
many tracks as they want on
any YouTube video, but you can
only edit a track that you
yourself created.
So I created these three guys,
nobody else can edit them, but
you could go here and
add your own thing.
So that kind of sucks, because
if you see an error in one of
my annotations here, there's
nothing you can do about it
aside from creating your own
track and saying, OK, if you
look above, that's not a G,
that should be an F. But I
will be implementing a
way of collaborating.
There's a bunch of different
models that I'm looking at,
like a Github model where you
would maybe create a clone of
my track and make some changes
and then make a pull request,
of course with none of
that geeky lingo.
Or like a Wikipedia model where
everything's just open
and anything can be edited
by anyone and it's
really easy to revert.
Looking at different
ways of doing that.
So that's the long answer
to your question.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh,
this is great.
Have you received any early
feedback from your users?
Anything you're willing
to share?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Yeah,
it's basically
been unanimously awesome.
Guitarists are saying this is
like the best way of learning
that they've ever seen.
Because, I mean, when you
compare it to the state of the
art, the state of the art is
like this data here, which is
called guitar tablature, that's
the name of this if
you're not familiar with it.
But that's generally available
in ASCII text format, so it's
kind of really lousy
to learn from.
Plus you have the original
recording and the philosophy
of the site is that you learn a
lot better when you see the
notes and you hear them
at the same time.
So, yeah, people love it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
This is great.
So now the second part of this
presentation was you showing
us how well you were able
to improve your
skills using this program.
So how about that?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Yes,
I suppose I should
get back on the chats.
So you want me to
play this song?
"The Star Spangled Banner?"
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Show
us what you got.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: OK,
get the guitar out.
Hopefully you guys can see it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah,
we can see you fine.
And this will be the short
version, not the Superbowl
long, extended version right?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Yes, this
will be very short.
How's the audio?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: You
sound amazing.
You look amazing.
[MUSIC - "THE STAR
SPANGLED BANNER"]
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Yay.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Nice, well
obviously the product works.
So thank you very much
for doing this.
I know there's a lot of pressure
performing live on
YouTube in front of millions
of users that are
watching us right now.
So next I had a couple of
technical questions.
Can you tell us a little bit
more about how your product is
implemented?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Definitely.
Let me just adjust
the thing here.
Well, it uses the YouTube API
and that lets me control the
YouTube player from JavaScript
and say obvious things like
play and pause.
I can do seek to go to
this moment in the
video, and the looping.
So the looping--
there's no API for looping
in the YouTube API.
So I basically every 20
milliseconds check is there a
current selection, if so are you
with the selection, if not
then it goes to the beginning
of the selection.
My patent-pending looping
algorithm, very complicated.
So I do looping.
What else is there?
The whole app is
built in HTML5.
And it uses Canvas
for everything.
So all those tabs, the
annotations, that's all drawn
on Canvas one pixel at a time.
And that's kind of cool.
I think that it's one of the
most intense uses of Canvases
in like a real world app that
I've seen on the internet.
And what else about it.
The back end is Django.
But, honestly, the back
end is super boring.
It just talks JSON to get
the annotation data.
What else can I tell
you about it?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So
I had one question.
I've noticed you implemented
this playback speed.
And this is one of the early
apps that takes advantage of
this functionality.
Can you tell us a little more
about how that works?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Yeah, so that's
the half-speed thing,
which is a crucial feature.
And the way that works is very
easy, thanks to your API.
All you need to do is say
Set Playback Rate--
I think that's what
it's called--
and you get the number of the
playback rate that you want,
which for half speed
would be 0.5.
And for a given video there's
an API that tells you which
speeds are available,
so not all videos
have half speed available.
And that's basically
how it works.
You just say, set playback
rate 0.5 and it
just magically works.
And I haven't had to
do anything else,
so that's very nice.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool, cool.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: I would
like there to be more
granularity in those.
One of my user's tab requested
feature is like a 75% speed.
I'm actually curious
about this.
Do you know how that's
implemented?
Is it re-encoding video on
the fly, I'm assuming?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I
don't think so.
I think this is something
that must be
supported by the transcode.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: OK.
Interesting.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: But, yeah,
I will definitely pass that
feedback on to the team.
Since now that we have a nice
use case, I'm sure they're
going to be excited
to see this.
And then you are using the
iframe Player API.
You said this is an HTML5
JavaScript app, right?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Yes, using the
iframe API which puts the
video in an iframe in my site
and lets me control the
JavaScript.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
Are you using the
Data API at all?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Yeah, I'm using
the Data API to get the
title of the video and the
duration, so just the boring
metadata about it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And then you said you can
annotate arbitrary videos, is
that using the Search API?
Or you have to know
the video ID?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Oh yeah, that's
yet another API that
I'm using from you guys.
It's the Search API, so when you
do a search on the site it
actually hits YouTube via Ajax
and returns all the video
results for that search.
And then it cross references
it with my own data to tell
you whether that particular
video has any annotations.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Got it.
So that's where the
transcriptions is stored on
the back end in the
Django app?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Yes, exactly.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And
are you using V2 of
the Data API or V3?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: I think
I'm using V3.
I developed it a couple
months ago and I used
whatever was newest.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
Yeah, so that would be V3.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: OK.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
And then you mentioned that, as
far as the types of things
that come up--
playback speed, more
granularity, was one of the
feature requests you have
gotten from your users--
is there anything else that
surprised you while
developing the app?
Any other feedback that you
would like to share.
Anything that was
counter-intuitive?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Yeah, there's
a couple of things--
and as a preface to this
I should say, I totally
understand if you don't want to
implement them because it's
not a common use of
the YouTube API,
let's just say that.
One thing is the player,
the current position--
so as you saw on this demo, the
playhead, actually from
your perspective, the playhead
goes smoothly
across the time line.
And to do that what I do is I
ask the YouTube API every
couple of milliseconds
what is the current
position of the player.
And I realized that the API
only updates every 250
milliseconds, a couple
times a second.
And so if I just did that,
it would be like
bom, bom, bom, bom.
It would be very choppy.
It wouldn't be nice
and smooth.
So I have to do some tweening
there to update the playhead
so that it's nice and smooth
between changes of the
official value.
So all that is to say that it
would be awesome to have more
accuracy in those API calls of
what is the current position
of the playhead.
And that way I wouldn't
have to do that.
And if you pay very close
attention to the app you will
see a little jump or a skip
every 250 milliseconds as the
thing corrects itself.
And that just bothers me.
And for something like
Soundslice that has a lot
precision, is very oriented
around precision, that can be
kind of like, oh, I don't
trust the app
as much as I would.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: And a related
thing is that when you make a
loop on Soundslice, because
of my algorithm--
it doesn't even deserve to
be called an algorithm.
So if you make a loop, when the
playhead reaches the end
of the loop, it goes back
to the start of it.
Because it is inexact, I'm
just checking every 20
milliseconds--
have you reached the
end of the loop?
If so, put it back.
That means there's a window of
20 milliseconds that you might
get a little extra audio or
a little too little audio.
So if you have a loop that's
very small and you listen to
the music, you might hear the
end of the next note, a little
speck of it.
You might not hear it.
So it's inexact.
It's imprecise.
And that's bothered
a bunch of users.
And from your prospective, what
you might do is add a way
of adding an end time
to the play.
So you say, oh, I want to play
from here and then end there.
And have that ending
be very exact.
And that way the loops would
be super precise.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
So the end time is actually
exposed as a parameter.
Though it isn't a
part of the API.
But when initialize the player,
you can actually pass
an end time.
But then you'll have to,
I think, tier it
down to change it.
So that wouldn't work so well.
And then definitely going back
to a specific position, I
think the challenge there is
we are subject to key frame
limitation, so it may not
always be super exact.
Although it sounds like it's
sufficient for the application
with the 20 millisecond
or so delta.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY:
Yeah, it's OK.
And I think that the coolness
and the usefulness of having
this available for any YouTube
video outweighs those
limitations.
So I had a previous version on
the site that worked on any
MP3 and it was completely
precise down to the level of
the frame of an MP3.
And it was really nice
and precise, but it
didn't work on YouTube.
It only worked on the files
that you uploaded.
So it's all about
the trade offs.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, actually
while you were
playing it and showing me the
app, I was wondering whether
the visual feedback actually
also helps with
the learning process.
Like understanding exactly how
he gripped the guitar.
And I don't play guitar, but I
was just wondering whether
that actually is also helpful.
Because it's like yet another
signal for the student.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Definitely
the visual.
As I've transcribed a bunch of
stuff from my favorite guitar
players, I'm always looking up
at the video, seeing which
finger are they using, how is
their hand positioned, also
their right hand, are
they using a down
stroke or an up stroke?
That's very important
information.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool, cool.
Well, thank you very much
for joining us.
Let me see if we have any
questions in the moderator.
I see there's one question
from me.
So I guess I will
address that.
There is a question about
whether YouTube Developer
Relations is hiring.
The answer is yes.
We are hiring.
Both YouTube and Google
Developer Relations.
We're always looking for good
people to join our team.
If you'd like to learn
more, go to
developers.google.com/jobs.
Again, thank you very
much, Adrian.
Excellent app.
I think I'm going to try it out
and see if I can pick up
some guitar.
Actually my sister is a guitar
player, so maybe I'll join the
musical family.
Thank you very much again.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: All right,
thanks for having me.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thank you.
Bye.